so what would you like to see a sequel
to Disney's Tarzan one of the biggest
summer hits when it came out or just the
rapist those of a cartoon pilot series
throwing together and saying that makes
it a movie well you got the goddamn
ladder give Tarzan and Jane credit
that's not called Tarzan - no no we get
that later it's at least not pretending
that this is supposed to be a flowing
cinematic follow-up but with that said
why even watch it this is another
anthology of stories that aren't really
interesting are usually pointless
doesn't have the same animation doesn't
have the same voice actors they couldn't
even get Phil Collins back they just
replay one of his songs in the opening
and then have a completely different
artist at the end sing them out by the
story tied together about as well as
Cinderella to tie them together
Jane is excited because it's the
one-year anniversary of Tarzan marrying
her so she's trying to figure out the
best way to celebrate but every idea she
comes up with seems to have a really
annoying story attached to it the first
story is about her friends coming back
from England trying to save her even
though she doesn't need saving the
second is about some evil guys who come
to the island who trick Tarzan into
trying to show them where some diamonds
are no no the diamonds are here they're
the third story is about yet another
asshole who comes to the island just to
make things hard the moral of the story
is anyone who comes to the island not
wearing a dress it's going to be a dick
what makes these especially funny is
that everybody knows the story that's
being told oh I don't mean the audience
so we can guess everything that's going
to happen - I'm talking about the
characters they literally know
everything that happens they live
through it yet for some reason they're
sitting down and talking about it some
of them don't even end with the same
storyteller one of them starts off with
Jane telling the story and then as with
the elephant finishing it what happened
in between
as you can tell from the animation this
doesn't look especially cinematic and
looks more like a TV series which it
eventually became this was all just a
test to see if kids would watch Tarzan
and Jane in several different stories
well guess what people don't want to
test they want a movie they want a show
pick one and be it I guess for a TV show
the animation isn't that bad I mean if I
saw it on TV I think it'd be totally
acceptable the quality of the voice for
placement so rarely sound like the
original in fact some even sound a
little uncomfortable the only thing more
annoying than Rosie O'Donnell voice is
somebody impersonating Rosie O'Donnell
voice I was there I saw the eights
alright everybody sounds a little off it
is except for a gene well you know it's
not Minnie Driver whoever does the voice
acting LeBrock has unique energy to it
on top of that Elaine's boss plays one
of the villains now that's just ideal
acting and sometimes the friends get a
little bit of a laugh too
I don't know I think it's just the
people doing the impersonations they're
a little odd not the worst just kind of
awkward
it may even more awkward by some of
these lines this one woman clearly has
an attraction to Tarzan and talked about
how hot it would be if he was in a cage
okay you could put a fucking educational
cage he's go see cage weird nothing
about Tarzan and Jane feels big
authentic or genuine if you look on the
back or watch a preview you can catch on
to that very quickly it is what it is a
quick hash in to see if they can watch
this Disney series it looks that way it
plays that way is it even worth getting
bad angry over it's a waste of time some
kids might enjoy but I think everybody
can agree is entirely pointless
you